españa produce 5 millones de toneladas
de carne de cerdo cada año y cuenta con
más de 2000 explotaciones porcinas a
gran escala solo la región de castilla y
león cuenta con casi 500 hoy este modelo
económico está en el centro de una
batalla política
raquel con de es una de las pocas macro
ganaderas que abre sus puertas a la
prensa aquí tenemos una capacidad de 8
mil animales entre ellos hay mil cerdos
aquí al fondo están nuestras granjas y
por detrás tenemos cada año nacen casi
30.000 cerdos en esta gran a 20 personas
trabajan aquí a tiempo completo el
sector porcino es una importante fuente
de empleo en la región
hola roberto
qué estáis haciendo pasando amarronada
parte
vale pues venga vamos
la granja de raquel cumple con los
requisitos de la etiqueta española aenor
animal welfare se basa en las normas
europeas de bienestar animal hay unos
330 animales albergados y como podéis
ver están sueltas tienen espacios
sólidos para tumbarse tienen rejilla
tienen juguetes si vais a y al fondo
tienen sus juguetes para entretenerse
pero hacen lo que quieren se tiene en
cuenta las normas de bienestar que los
animales no tienen miedo no te huyen
sino que son animales que están bien
tratados este modelo fue desarrollado en
los años 70 para proporcionar carne
barata al mayor número de personas el
modelo de ganadería intensiva es ahora
cada vez más cuestionado en españa
principalmente por su impacto en el
medio ambiente quien dice que están mal
los animales y que no cumplimos con el
medio ambiente
sino nosotros como habéis podido
comprobar hemos instalado placas ponemos
sistemas de bebederos para que no tienen
agua boyas de nivel ya estamos más que
pendientes del medio ambiente
pero lo que más se critica es el
estiércol que contienen estas fosas
utilizado por los agricultores como
fertilizante natural este genera
contaminación en la capa freática del
suelo por acción de los nitritos
vamos a medir
el agua describimos que llegamos
en la región la calidad del agua de los
pozos se ha convertido en un problema
emilia vive en un pequeño pueblo cerca
de dos granjas de cerdos
ahora no tenemos
una vez cada dos meses ella mide el
nivel de nitrato en el agua aquí el
resultado es claro este agua no se puede
beber ni se puede cocinar
se podrían regar las plantas a lo mejor
agregar las plantas de nuevo con agua la
unión europea establece una
concentración máxima de 50 miligramos de
nitrato por un litro de agua más allá de
eso no es potable
emilia forma parte de un programa de
seguimiento creado por greenpeace que se
encarga de medir los hogares de las
personas pero su misión se ha vuelto
cada vez más difícil hay sitios donde
hemos empezado pero después ya no
quieren saber nada más porque parece ser
pues que ha habido amenazas y cosas
y te queman un tractor te cortan los
árboles del huerto te hacen alguna cosa
que se daña la polémica en torno a las
macro granjas se ha convertido en un
asunto político en españa el derechista
partido popular defiende su utilidad
económica mientras que el gobernante
partido socialista quiere un montarlas
al máximo pregúntale si no a los vecinos
a lo largo de toda españa' que están
sufriendo la contaminación de su suelo
en la contaminación del agua la
contaminación de olores y que se están
marchando de su población que ya sufría
la despoblación en esos territorios
[Aplausos]
esta marcha de protesta en el campo
cerca de valladolid es contra la
construcción de una gran granja de
cerdos a tres kilómetros del centro del
pueblo
a 200 metros estaríamos en la ribera del
pisuerga plantean que la barrera de los
árboles es la que va a frenar los olores
y los gases tóxicos plantean que el
cerro de la montaña es una barrera una
barrera natural y son totalmente
depósitos para este alcalde socialista
los impactos de la instalación de una
macro granja serán mucho más negativos
que positivos la gente se viene a
cabezón porque le gusta la zona natural
los parajes naturales y esto va a hacer
que la gente pues pierda el atractivo
que tiene y no sé no solamente no venga
vecinos nuevos sino que los que hay
puedan irse aquí en la zona alrededor
tenemos la ruta del vino cigales que
están asociadas pues muchísimas empresas
muchísimos recursos turísticos que
también se verían afectados
para aliviar las tensiones algunas
regiones están revisando sus políticas
agrícolas la comunidad de castilla-la
mancha' ha decidido congelar todas las
solicitudes de nuevas granjas de más de
2.000 animales hasta el 2025